this is the most excited i've been about
an announcement in a very long time
get ready gen z because the hype house
is officially coming to tv
on thursday netflix announced the
popular digital influencers
who have over 120 million followers on
tick tock
will be starring in a new unscripted
series that will reveal
a side of themselves and their
relationships that we rarely see
if you guys were here for 24 hours you'd
be like you need a reality tv show
the cast will feature hype house
veterans thomas petrue and chase hudson
alongside social media staples nikita
dragon
larae alex warren and more thomas also
confirmed the news on his blog
revealing that partnering with netflix
has been a long-term dream since
launching the hype house in 2019.
if i wanted to do a reality show with
our house i wanted to make it the best
reality show possible and i wanted to
partner with one of my favorite
companies i spent the next
year trying to make that happen and if
you think about it thomas pretty much
manifested this in 2020
when he spoke to e.t about the impact of
tick-tock it's the only platform
that is specialized directly towards the
next generation of kids
which every brand's interested in every
network's interested and everyone's
interested in
because all these companies like netflix
and disney they're just like
how do we hit them because the
millennials already love us they already
support us
as for what we can expect on the show in
december alex warren told dt that there
will be some drama between thomas and
sway house member
bryce hall going back to the the hype
house reality series will we see
bryce and thomas's issues
potentially play out we'll see the
issues for sure
that's that's a given i think that's
just something that you know
those two i honestly think they'll get
married before me and cover but
i don't know i think that i think that
it's a lot
it's a lot to play out i think it's more
exciting to like
get thrown off by a lot of things but
you know i
i i'm very excited for the dynamic and
of course we can expect to see a lot of
real moments of what it's like to be a
true
influencer what are we gonna learn about
you and the house when we tune in to
that show
um i think that you know you're going to
learn about a lot of people i think that
so many especially with this industry
and especially with the job that we take
on
you know what we put out you judge what
you
what based on what is put out about said
person i think that you know
this is more of an inside look on what
happens in the house and how we're all
human
in general when people have following on
the internet they're held to a pedestal
and you know made examples up and i
highly agree with that but also
you know i feel like people are going to
realize that a lot of us are human and
make a lot of mistakes